baseball is more entertaining than
Cricket
three two one
yeah I mean what a cricket is a okay
baseball is baseball Cricket's much more
enjoyable than is that baseball is more
entertaining than crazy
[Applause]
yes but I'm a huge Dodgers fan so you
can does make a difference it's not as
fun Sport AS cricket
I love crickets I like watching the slow
game when I have the time to which has
been you know a rare commodity in recent
years what's happening what's the slow
game what's the fast game I've only
watched a version you have a test match
which is uh it can span anything up to
what five days boys is it girls what
what do you think yes about five is the
maximum and you can have what are you
doing